So this is the last blog I'm going to be
doing in this apartment.
I'm moving out of here next week.
So say goodbye to the beautiful brick
wall that I love so much.
Also coffee on a Tuesday and flogged.
Fifty nine.
Okay.
Nationally,
we've dealt with our share of tragedies
in recent months.
Last October,
Hurricane Sandy caused an estimated
$71,000,000,000
in damage to the east coast in December.
20 children were shot and killed at
Sandy Hook elementary in Connecticut in
April.
Two bombs were set off at the Boston
marathon and just last week a massive
tornado literally uprooted and Oklahoma
town killing 24 internationally.
There are of course,
tragedies beyond counting for some such
tragedies are a way of life,
a daily affair for those who have
experienced the paint,
the residents at the Jersey shore,
the parents of the children at Newtown,
the marathon runners who trained and
trained and were robbed in violence of
their triumph there opens up beneath
them a new basement of feeling which
many of us cannot and hopefully we'll
never know,
such pain in this country,
especially in those relatively safe
neighborhoods like the one I grew up in,
must be alienating.
I've never experienced intense
suffering,
never seen death or had someone very
close to me die.
So by what language could the victim
communicate to me,
his sorrow?
What responsibility do I have to feel,
and what responsibility do I have to
feel the day to day suffering for those
in parts of the world to whom such deep
pain is not alienating but inclusionary.
For a short time after college,
I studied philosophy and I've found that
the more I read,
the more reading seemed insufficient.
I was studying philosophy to figure out
what to do and ironically,
as the concept of truth became
increasingly murky to me,
how to act became increasingly playing,
the only thing really worth doing,
I've found was helping other people.
Of course,
people need help in a variety of ways.
In Stardust memories.
Woody Allen's
says,
excuse me,
you don't have enough to eat or
something that becomes a major problem
in has become very clear cut,
but what happens if you're living in a
more,
you know,
a more affluent society and you're lucky
enough to to not have to worry about
that.
Let's say you're surviving,
so then you problems become,
how can I fall in love or why can't they
fall in love more accurately and why do
I age and die and what meaning can my
life possibly have?
The issues become very complex for,
you know,
for a guy that makes a lot of funny
movies,
you're kind of a depressive.
You know,
Alan is describing mazlow's hierarchy of
needs,
a hierarchical list of our human needs
often shown as a pyramid from our most
fundamental to our most complex,
from our physiological needs of food and
shelter,
to our need of safety,
of friendship,
self esteem,
and finally of self actualization,
our needs of creativity and morale.
The idea is that one cannot ascend the
pyramid until the needs of lower orders
are satisfied as a novelist and Vlogger,
as one with food,
shelter,
safety,
self-esteem,
friends,
I aim to treat issues of self
actualization for myself and others.
That's what this blog is,
but that's also a choice.
It means that my experience in its
attempts at profundity will be holy and
necessarily different from mine.
This is Sean Ahmed of the uncultured
project.
Sean withdrew from Grad School after
hearing a speech by Dr Jeffrey Sachs
about poverty.
He liquidated his savings and left his
life to start a project in which he uses
technology and the web to bring those in
need together with what they need.
Teaming up with various organizations.
Sean has provided clean water to
villages,
rebuilt a high school,
destroyed by a psych loan,
provided emergency relief in multiple
disaster areas and helped over 10,000
children through longterm health worker
programs.
I just returned from Bangladesh where
two major events happened.
First was the garment factory collapse,
which killed over 1000,
100 people.
Also episodes of Muslim extremist
violence,
uh,
which over a quarter million Muslim
extremist congregated in the city.
There were clashes with security forces
in many.
What I'm feeling right now are
Bangladeshis,
resilience to tragedy.
And it's very hard to talk about this in
a way that doesn't romanticize the poor
or those suffering because in many
respects,
because they can handle it or they seem
to be handling it.
And I couldn't.
Sometimes it makes me feel like I should
put them on a pedestal for me.
I can actually have a normal day and
then I could go to an h and m and then
all of a sudden I'm getting flashbacks
of the garment factory collapse.
Or I can watch a movie where people die
and they get flashbacks of the more.
I saw corpses from the Muslim
extremists.
We're.
Yeah,
I don't.
Let's not show them just to keep it on
me.
Sean is livid.
The conclusion I came to a few years
ago,
a conclusion that I entertained in the
comfort of my largely painless
existence,
but one which I did not see through for
reasons of family,
vocation and cowardice.
To see what maslow doesn't cover is
whether or not it's okay to ascend the
hierarchy of needs when just one other
person with whom you share the world
lacks the fundamentals of life for any
need of a lower order.
When people ask me,
I tell them that I'm a writer because I
feel I have a knack for it because I
believed that I could add something
significant to the history of
literature.
About 60 percent of me believes that
more or less by turns.
Of course,
these things don't have to be mutually
exclusive.
The vlog brothers,
self actualizer is if there ever were,
have raised millions of dollars for
charities through Kiva Dot Com and the
project for awesome last year.
$14 of that project for awesome money
went to kids in need of desks in Milan
this year.
Tens of thousands of dollars.
These go into the uncultured project.
These things make a real difference in
the world,
but now I will return to my videos in my
writing.
Sean will return to his hands on work in
Bangladesh and though sat just inches
apart.
We are separated by a Gulf of
experience,
a Gulf of pain and suffering and a
sensory knowledge of privileges that
feel to me like mere facts,
a golf which I cannot cross.
Let me go for which many in Bangladesh
and to some extent me can never cross.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
Thank you.
So,
so here's the do one take videos.
So I get to do this.
It will be here for quite a while.
So if you should check out his other
videos,
he will have invitations to various
video,
but no on what you're seeing us right
now.
There'll be an annotation to the
uncultured project.
Goes there and watch all of Sean's
videos.
I admire everything he does.
I think it's absolutely incredible and I
think you'll think that to get here.